This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。保证真人。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《以防万一》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全展开的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套隐形的铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力，就必须这样做，请听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.|||在 AHA 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《以防万一》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你曾多次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。大批互联网侦探花费了大量精力才揭开了一个令人不安的规律。还有两名男子也遭遇了同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.|||我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情网》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. everybody, welcome back to the podcast, welcome back to the show, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Thank you for joining me. Thank you for joining me for another episode. This week, we are talking about therapy and we're extending a discussion that we've had quite a bit over on the Psychology of Your 20s Instagram. So if you're following me over there,
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. everybody, welcome back to the podcast, welcome back to the show, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Thank you for joining me. Thank you for joining me for another episode. This week, we are talking about therapy and we're extending a discussion that we've had quite a bit over on the Psychology of Your 20s Instagram. So if you're following me over there,|||相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝，在 Iheart 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》，这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转型及其对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到播客，欢迎回到节目中，新听友、老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。感谢你们的加入。感谢你们陪伴我收听又一期节目。本周，我们将探讨心理治疗，并将我们在《二十岁心理学》Instagram 上进行过多次的讨论进一步延伸。所以如果你在那边关注了我，
you may have seen some of these conversations come up a bit recently, but after mulling it over, little bit more, I thought we needed to devote an entire episode to this topic, especially as a podcast that is devoted to those of us in our 20s. Therapy is such a crucial resource for this decade, but also very confusing if you haven't been exposed to this type of help before. You know, these years of our life, they are defined by so many huge life changes, disruptive events, breakups, breakdowns, even death sometimes, and it's often when we begin to recognize the trauma we have carried since childhood, the behaviors that may be self-sabotaging, the boundaries we find it difficult to set, and the aspects of our mental health that we may be struggling with.
you may have seen some of these conversations come up a bit recently, but after mulling it over, little bit more, I thought we needed to devote an entire episode to this topic, especially as a podcast that is devoted to those of us in our 20s. Therapy is such a crucial resource for this decade, but also very confusing if you haven't been exposed to this type of help before. You know, these years of our life, they are defined by so many huge life changes, disruptive events, breakups, breakdowns, even death sometimes, and it's often when we begin to recognize the trauma we have carried since childhood, the behaviors that may be self-sabotaging, the boundaries we find it difficult to set, and the aspects of our mental health that we may be struggling with.|||你可能最近已经看到过其中一些话题的讨论了，但在仔细琢磨了一会儿之后，我觉得我们需要用一整期节目来专门探讨这个话题，特别是作为一个专为我们这个年纪的年轻人制作的播客。对于这十年来说，心理治疗是一个至关重要的资源，但如果你以前没有接触过这种帮助，它也会非常令人困惑。你知道，我们生命中的这些年，充满了无数重大的生活变化、颠覆性的事件、分手、崩溃，有时甚至是死亡，往往也就是在这个时候，我们开始意识到自己自童年以来一直背负着的创伤、那些可能带有自我破坏性质的行为、我们发现很难设定的界限，以及我们可能正在苦苦挣扎的心理健康方面的问题。
And in these situations, reaching out for professional help is one of the best things you can do for your development and long-term mental health. So welcome everyone to your comprehensive audio guide to therapy in your 20s. If you're listening to this with the intention of getting some professional psychological assistance for whatever you're struggling with, I really hope it goes without saying that I am so proud of you that this is a fantastic decision and you deserve so much credit for taking this step on your mental health journey. There is no shame, no stigma here,
And in these situations, reaching out for professional help is one of the best things you can do for your development and long-term mental health. So welcome everyone to your comprehensive audio guide to therapy in your 20s. If you're listening to this with the intention of getting some professional psychological assistance for whatever you're struggling with, I really hope it goes without saying that I am so proud of you that this is a fantastic decision and you deserve so much credit for taking this step on your mental health journey. There is no shame, no stigma here,|||在这种情况下，寻求专业帮助是你为了自身发展和长期心理健康所能做的最好的事情之一。欢迎大家收听这份关于二十岁心理治疗的综合音频指南。如果你收听本节目是为了针对你正在挣扎的某些问题寻求专业的心理援助，我真的希望不用多说你也知道，我为你感到无比骄傲，这是一个极好的决定，你在心理健康之旅中迈出这一步，理应获得极大的赞许。这里没有羞耻，没有污名化，
because I genuinely think that everyone should receive therapy and I wish it was more accessible and less stigmatized than it is. I get so many messages from people who are really struggling to find affordable help or someone in their local area who isn't booked out for the next five months. I think accessibility is a massive issue. impacting the mental health community, impacting people with mental health problems or conditions, especially after the pandemic and the lockdowns when the demand for mental health services really skyrocketed. And I know it can be so frustrating. But I want to provide all of the information
because I genuinely think that everyone should receive therapy and I wish it was more accessible and less stigmatized than it is. I get so many messages from people who are really struggling to find affordable help or someone in their local area who isn't booked out for the next five months. I think accessibility is a massive issue. impacting the mental health community, impacting people with mental health problems or conditions, especially after the pandemic and the lockdowns when the demand for mental health services really skyrocketed. And I know it can be so frustrating. But I want to provide all of the information|||因为我真心认为每个人都应该接受心理治疗，我也希望它能比现在更容易获得、受到的污名化更少。我收到了太多人的私信，他们真的很难找到负担得起的帮助，或者在当地找不到未来五个月内没有被预约满的专业人士。我认为可及性是一个巨大的问题。它影响着心理健康群体，影响着有心理健康问题或状况的人，特别是在大流行和封锁之后，心理健康服务的需求真正呈指数级飙升。我知道这会让人感到非常沮丧。但我想提供所有的信息，
that I can for those who may be thinking about committing to therapy because we know anecdotally and from all the evidence that it really does have the capacity to change our lives. And like I had just mentioned before, there are so many financial and logistical reasons sometimes for stopping us. And one of those logistical reasons, one of those other reasons, I guess, is that it can be really scary and novel and new. There is so much stigma about being deemed crazy because you're taking care of your mental health. And that message is in no way supported by this platform. We are pro-therapy. We are pro-seeking help. You're not weak for going to therapy. You're not crazy. I just think that everyone should be able to easily find their way into receiving
that I can for those who may be thinking about committing to therapy because we know anecdotally and from all the evidence that it really does have the capacity to change our lives. And like I had just mentioned before, there are so many financial and logistical reasons sometimes for stopping us. And one of those logistical reasons, one of those other reasons, I guess, is that it can be really scary and novel and new. There is so much stigma about being deemed crazy because you're taking care of your mental health. And that message is in no way supported by this platform. We are pro-therapy. We are pro-seeking help. You're not weak for going to therapy. You're not crazy. I just think that everyone should be able to easily find their way into receiving|||供那些可能正在考虑进行心理治疗的人参考，因为我们通过轶事和所有证据都知道，它确实有能力改变我们的生活。就像我刚才提到的那样，有时会有很多财务和后勤方面的原因阻碍我们。其中一个后勤原因，我想另一个原因可能是，这可能会让人感到非常害怕、新奇和陌生。仅仅因为你照顾自己的心理健康就被认为是个疯子，这种污名化太严重了。本平台绝不支持这种观念。我们支持心理治疗。我们支持寻求帮助。你去接受心理治疗并不代表你软弱。你不是疯子。我只是认为每个人都应该能够轻松地找到途径去接受
psychological help when they need it. So today I really want to break down every element of the therapy journey so that it can be perhaps a little bit easier for you and for anyone listening and get us closer to the point where getting psychological help is as easy as going to your family doctor. So we're going to discuss a lot of things, a lot of crucial elements of the therapy journey of how to access therapy. We're going to start off by talking about how to recognize when you may need therapy and some extra mental health assistance, how to access therapy and offering a bit of a guide into those first early steps. I really want to talk about the different types of therapy or counseling that you may be able to access and why they differ, how to find the right therapist
psychological help when they need it. So today I really want to break down every element of the therapy journey so that it can be perhaps a little bit easier for you and for anyone listening and get us closer to the point where getting psychological help is as easy as going to your family doctor. So we're going to discuss a lot of things, a lot of crucial elements of the therapy journey of how to access therapy. We're going to start off by talking about how to recognize when you may need therapy and some extra mental health assistance, how to access therapy and offering a bit of a guide into those first early steps. I really want to talk about the different types of therapy or counseling that you may be able to access and why they differ, how to find the right therapist|||在其需要时获得心理帮助。所以今天我真的很想剖析心理治疗之旅的每一个要素，这样或许能为你和所有收听节目的听众减轻一些难度，让我们离“寻求心理帮助就像去看家庭医生一样简单”这一目标更近一步。因此，我们将讨论很多事情，探讨治疗之旅的许多关键要素以及如何获得心理治疗。我们将从如何识别自己何时可能需要心理治疗和额外的心理健康援助开始讲起，然后探讨如何获得治疗，并为最初的几个步骤提供一些指导。我真的很想谈谈你可能会接触到的不同类型的心理治疗或咨询，以及它们为什么会有所不同，如何找到合适的治疗师，
and why it may take a little while to find the right person for you. I really want to talk about some of my non-negotiables around the people that I see for my mental health or the therapist that I speak to when I do find that I need some extra assistance. So we're going to talk through that and then what to expect at therapy, especially in your first few sessions and some of the myths that surround this practice. You know, it's not always like the movies where a person lays on a couch and we examine their dreams and you're not always going to be. You're not always going to having breakthrough after breakthrough, you know, in tears every session or walking out magically changed. I think we sometimes expect that when we go and, you know, get help. And it's a really
and why it may take a little while to find the right person for you. I really want to talk about some of my non-negotiables around the people that I see for my mental health or the therapist that I speak to when I do find that I need some extra assistance. So we're going to talk through that and then what to expect at therapy, especially in your first few sessions and some of the myths that surround this practice. You know, it's not always like the movies where a person lays on a couch and we examine their dreams and you're not always going to be. You're not always going to having breakthrough after breakthrough, you know, in tears every session or walking out magically changed. I think we sometimes expect that when we go and, you5|||以及为什么找到一个适合你的人可能需要花一点时间。我真的想谈谈我在选择心理健康服务人员或在我发现自己需要额外帮助时所交流的治疗师时的一些底线和非妥协原则。所以我们要讨论这些，然后是关于心理治疗的预期，特别是在头几次治疗中会发生什么，以及围绕这项实践的一些迷思。你知道，这并不总是像电影里那样，一个人躺在沙发上，我们分析他的梦境，而且你也不会总是。你不会总是取得一个又一个的突破，你知道，每次治疗都泪流满面，或者神奇般地焕然一新地走出来。我想我们有时在去寻求帮助时会抱有这种期待，
lovely promise and super appealing, but it doesn't always work out that way. And I think it's important to be realistic about what you can expect and about how therapy works and that it takes some time. And as someone who has done a lot of therapy, I run a psychology podcast. I've had my fair share of therapists, of psychologists, and you know, I've had my hiatuses, I've gone back to therapy, I've seen different people for different issues. So I really want to sit down today and outline in detail what this process is like. And I hope that it will remove some of the mysticism and fear around what I think is really an essential practice for everyone and hopefully normalize the process of asking for help and then receiving what you.
get help. And it's a really lovely promise and super appealing, but it doesn't always work out that way. And I think it's important to be realistic about what you can expect and about how therapy works and that it takes some time. And as someone who has done a lot of therapy, I run a psychology podcast. I've had my fair share of therapists, of psychologists, and you know, I've had my hiatuses, I've gone back to therapy, I've seen different people for different issues. So I really want to sit down today and outline in detail what this process is like. And I hope that it will remove some of the mysticism and fear around what I think is really an essential practice for everyone and hopefully normalize the process of asking for help and then receiving what you.|||这是一个非常美好的承诺，也超级吸引人，但事情并不总是那样发展的。我认为，对于你能有什么期待、心理治疗是如何运作的以及它需要时间这些事情，保持现实的看法是很重要的。作为一个做过很多心理治疗、经营着一个心理学播客的人。我经历过不少治疗师、心理学家，你知道的，我曾中断过，也重新回到了心理治疗中，为了不同的问题看过不同的人。所以我今天真的很想坐下来，详细概述这个过程是怎样的。我希望这能消除一些围绕着我认为对每个人来说都至关重要的实践的神秘主义和恐惧，并希望将寻求帮助然后获得所需支持的过程常态化。
you need. So there is a lot to cover today. So I'm going to stop waffling. I'm going to stop talking. And let's get straight into our complete guide to therapy in your 20. If you are listening to this, you've already taken the first major step. Congratulations. You have been able to acknowledge that you may not be able to go through whatever you're going through on your own. That is amazing self-awareness. And I hope it goes without saying, like, I said before that I'm very proud of you. Life can be really intense sometimes. It can throw us some real curveballs that we might call major life events such as the death of a family member, a chronic illness diagnosis, but sometimes the cumulative stress of everyday life can also build
you need. So there is a lot to cover today. So I'm going to stop waffling. I'm going to stop talking. And let's get straight into our complete guide to therapy in your 20. If you are listening to this, you've already taken the first major step. Congratulations. You have been able to acknowledge that you may not be able to go through whatever you're going through on your own. That is amazing self-awareness. And I hope it goes without saying, like, I said before that I'm very proud of you. Life can be really intense sometimes. It can throw us some real curveballs that we might call major life events such as the death of a family member, a chronic illness diagnosis, but sometimes the cumulative stress of everyday life can also build|||你所需要的东西。所以今天要涵盖的内容很多。所以我要停止废话了。我要停止空谈了。让我们直接进入我们的二十岁心理治疗完全指南。如果你正在听这个，你已经迈出了重大的一步。恭喜你。你已经能够承认，你可能无法独自挺过你正在经历的任何事情。这是一种了不起的自我觉察。我希望不用多说，就像我之前说的那样，我为你感到非常骄傲。生活有时会非常紧张。它会给我们抛出一些真正的曲线球，我们可以称之为重大的生活事件，例如家庭成员的去世、慢性病的诊断，但有时日常生活中累积的压力也会积聚
up to the point where we need to pause and look after our mental health. I think it's also worth recognizing before we jump in that our family and friends can only do so much. They have their own struggles and things impacting their mental health. And I think it's not always realistic that we can always rely on them in hard times, not for all of our emotional needs, at least. We're just doing our best. Sometimes, you know, we need that outside support, especially in instances where you may not even have that level of family support or recognition from your parents or people that are close to you that mental health is a serious concern. And that is so hard to not have that essential support and validation that we need. But in both of those instances, a psychologist or a therapist can provide
up to the point where we need to pause and look after our mental health. I think it's also worth recognizing before we jump in that our family and friends can only do so much. They have their own struggles and things impacting their mental health. And I think it's not always realistic that we can always rely on them in hard times, not for all of our emotional needs, at least. We're just doing our best. Sometimes, you know, we need that outside support, especially in instances where you may not even have that level of family support or recognition from your parents or people that are close to you that mental health is a serious concern. And that is so hard to not have that essential support and validation that we need. But in both of those instances, a psychologist or a therapist can provide|||到我们需要暂停下来照顾自己心理健康的程度。我认为在我们深入探讨之前，还值得认识到的是，我们的家人和朋友能做的也十分有限。他们有自己的挣扎和影响他们心理健康的事情。而且我认为，在艰难时期总是指望他们并非总是现实的，至少无法满足我们所有的情感需求。我们只是在尽最大努力。有时，你知道的，我们需要那种外界的支持，特别是在你甚至没有那种家庭支持水平，或者父母或亲近的人不承认心理健康是一个严重问题的情况下。没有那种我们必需的支持和认可，是多么的艰难。但在上述这两种情况下，心理学家或治疗师都可以提供
so much value, so much validation, the psychological skills, and even the language to understand what you're going through and communicate that to others. Therapy is also entirely confidential. There is no judgment. You are often paying for this support. So you get to ask for what you would like from your sessions. And it is a place to be entirely vulnerable in a way that sometimes we cannot be with our family or friends to process your emotions away from the outside world.
so much value, so much validation, the psychological skills, and even the language to understand what you're going through and communicate that to others. Therapy is also entirely confidential. There is no judgment. You are often paying for this support. So you get to ask for what you would like from your sessions. And it is a place to be entirely vulnerable in a way that sometimes we cannot be with our family or friends to process your emotions away from the outside world.|||如此多的价值、如此多的认可、心理技能，甚至是理解你正在经历的事情并将其传达给别人的语言。心理治疗也是完全保密的。这里没有评判。你通常是为这种支持付费的。所以你可以索取你希望从咨询中获得的东西。这是一个可以完全展现脆弱的地方，这种脆弱有时我们在家人或朋友面前是无法表现出来的，它能让你远离外部世界，处理自己的情绪。
So let's talk about some of the signs or reasons that you might be considering or should consider therapy. The first reason is if you've just been through a major life event. These may include things like the death of a partner, of a family member, being fired, graduating uni, even. Not all of them have to be negative, but they do all represent an unscheduled, uncontrollable event that usually signifies a major life change. There is actually a scale of the 10 most stressful life events that you can access online. And some of them even include positive things like a wedding or moving house. And when these events occur, there is a heightened likelihood that we are going to experience some level of stress or even distress. You know, they are a huge adjustment. So if you can
So let's talk about some of the signs or reasons that you might be considering or should consider therapy. The first reason is if you've just been through a major life event. These may include things like the death of a partner, of a family member, being fired, graduating uni, even. Not all of them have to be negative, but they do all represent an unscheduled, uncontrollable event that usually signifies a major life change. There is actually a scale of the 10 most stressful life events that you can access online. And some of them even include positive things like a wedding or moving house. And when these events occur, there is a heightened likelihood that we are going to experience some level of stress or even distress. You know, they are a huge adjustment. So if you can|||所以我们来谈谈一些你可能会考虑或应该考虑心理治疗的迹象或原因。第一个原因是你刚刚经历了一场重大的生活事件. 这些可能包括伴侣去世、家庭成员去世、被解雇、甚至大学毕业。并非所有这些都必须是负面的，但它们都代表了一个未预料到、不可控的事件，通常标志着重大的生活变革。网络上其实有一个关于十大最具压力的生活事件的量表，你可以查阅。其中甚至还包括诸如婚礼或搬家等积极的事情。当这些事件发生时，我们经历某种程度的压力甚至苦恼的可能性就会增加。你知道，这是巨大的调整。所以如果你能
recognize that something major has just occurred in your life, whether you're coping or not, I think it's worth reaching out and seeing if you're able to see someone, for some guidance. The second reason is overwhelming stress and anxiety. Maybe you are working extended hours at work or at uni and struggling to stay on top of things. Stress places immense pressure on our nervous system and our brain's ability to cope. And if it's left unaddressed, it significantly increases your likelihood of developing mental health problems like depression and anxiety. So if you are finding that you're suffering from things like excessive fatigue, anxiety, stress, if you're getting sick very often, that's really worth, I think, sitting with taking a step back if you
recognize that something major has just occurred in your life, whether you're coping or not, I think it's worth reaching out and seeing if you're able to see someone, for some guidance. The second reason is overwhelming stress and anxiety. Maybe you are working extended hours at work or at uni and struggling to stay on top of things. Stress places immense pressure on our nervous system and our brain's ability to cope. And if it's left unaddressed, it significantly increases your likelihood of developing mental health problems like depression and anxiety. So if you are finding that you're suffering from things like excessive fatigue, anxiety, stress, if you're getting sick very often, that's really worth, I think, sitting with taking a step back if you|||意识到你生活中刚刚发生了重大事件，无论你是否在应对，我都认为值得伸出援手，看看你是否能找个人寻求一些指导。第二个原因是不堪重负的压力和焦虑。也许你在工作或大学里长时间加班，艰难地维持着各项事务。压力对我们的神经系统和大脑的应对能力施加了巨大的压力。如果置之不理，它会显著增加你患上抑郁症和焦虑症等心理健康问题的可能性。所以如果你发现自己正遭受过度疲劳、焦虑、压力等问题的困扰，如果你经常生病，我认为这真的很值得你去面对，如果你能的话，退一步
can and prioritizing your mental health and getting some help. You know, work can wait. A bad grade is not going to ruin you, trust me, but poor mental health will have consequences that are going to last much longer than your academic performance or your chances at a promotion. And I think also making sure that you find the help you need through someone to speak to and process your emotions and stress will mean that you can bounce back and experience that level of functioning that you would like sooner rather than later. The next reason is if you're starting to recognize unhealthy habits or behaviors. Our 20s is often when we,
can and prioritizing your mental health and getting some help. You know, work can wait. A bad grade is not going to ruin you, trust me, but poor mental health will have consequences that are going to last much longer than your academic performance or your chances at a promotion. And I think also making sure that you find the help you need through someone to speak to and process your emotions and stress will mean that you can bounce back and experience that level of functioning that you would like sooner rather than later. The next reason is if you're starting to recognize unhealthy habits or behaviors. Our 20s is often when we,|||优先考虑你的心理健康并寻求一些帮助。你知道，工作可以等。一次糟糕的成绩不会毁了你，相信我，但糟糕的心理健康所带来的后果将持续比你的学业表现或晋升机会长得多。而且我认为，确保你通过找人倾诉并处理你的情绪和压力来找到所需的帮助，这意味着你可以更快地恢复过来，体验到你所期望的运作水平。下一个原因是你开始意识到不健康的习惯或行为。我们的二十岁往往是我们开始
begin to recognize some of the unhealthy and self-sabotaging habits or behaviors that we've picked up in our childhood and in our adolescence. I'm thinking things like unhealthy eating habits to procrastination, maybe you isolate during times of stress. If you have noticed something about your habits and behaviors that you would like to change, a psychologist can really help guide you through this process and provide some objective clarity. The next reason is if you are having symptoms of a mental health condition like depression or phobias or anything else, this is not something to take lightly and I'm not going to speak to specific conditions because I do feel like that could take a while, but I'm going to speak
begin to recognize some of the unhealthy and self-sabotaging habits or behaviors that we've picked up in our childhood and in our adolescence. I'm thinking things like unhealthy eating habits to procrastination, maybe you isolate during times of stress. If you have noticed something about your habits and behaviors that you would like to change, a psychologist can really help guide you through this process and provide some objective clarity. The next reason is if you are having symptoms of a mental health condition like depression or phobias or anything else, this is not something to take lightly and I'm not going to speak to specific conditions because I do feel like that could take a while, but I'm going to speak|||认识到我们在童年和青春期养成的某些不健康和自我破坏的习惯或行为的时候。我想到的事情从不健康的饮食习惯到拖延症，也许你在压力大的时候会自我孤立。如果你注意到你的某些习惯和行为是你想要改变的，心理学家真的可以帮助指导你完成这个过程，并提供一些客观的清晰度。下一个原因是你出现了某种心理健康状况的症状，比如抑郁症、恐惧症或其他任何东西，这绝不是一件可以轻视的事情，我不会去谈论具体的状况，因为我觉得那可能会花上一段时间，但我会
from experience when I say whatever you're going through if it's indicating that there's something deeper going on, the longer you leave this, the worse it will become. And the sooner you get help, the better you will feel. You know, I'm not trying to say that to scare anyone, but perhaps just encourage you. You know how it feels when you're happy and okay. So trust yourself when you're feeling off. If your thought patterns are spiraling, if you can't find anything that brings you joy or you are avoiding certain activities or situations, that's your cue. It's time to get some help. Of course, I think a lot of these are all to do with very internal and individual problems, but sometimes there can be problems in our relationships and in the kind of broader relationship
from experience when I say whatever you're going through if it's indicating that there's something deeper going on, the longer you leave this, the worse it will become. And the sooner you get help, the better you will feel. You know, I'm not trying to say that to scare anyone, but perhaps just encourage you. You know how it feels when you're happy and okay. So trust yourself when you're feeling off. If your thought patterns are spiraling, if you can't find anything that brings you joy or you are avoiding certain activities or situations, that's your cue. It's time to get some help. Of course, I think a lot of these are all to do with very internal and individual problems, but sometimes there can be problems in our relationships and in the kind of broader relationship|||结合经验说，无论你正在经历什么，如果它表明有什么更深层次的事情正在发生，你拖延的时间越长，情况就会变得越糟。你越早寻求帮助，你就会感觉越好。你知道，我这么说并不是为了吓唬任何人，或许只是为了鼓励你。你知道当你快乐并且状态良好时的感觉。所以当你感觉不对劲时，要相信自己。如果你的思维模式陷入恶性循环，如果你找不到任何能带给你快乐的事物，或者你在逃避某些活动或情况，这就是你的信号。是时候寻求一些帮助了。当然，我认为这其中有很多都与非常内在和个人的问题有关，但有时我们的关系中以及在更广泛的关系生态系统中
ecosystem in which we're situated that can really have consequences for our mental health. maybe with your intimate partner, with your family, with your friends, relationships are really emotionally complex. And sometimes there's friction, sometimes there's things that just aren't quite aligning. And you can't see clearly what's actually happening when you're wrapped up in a situation, but a therapist can.
ecosystem in which we're situated that can really have consequences for our mental health. maybe with your intimate partner, with your family, with your friends, relationships are really emotionally complex. And sometimes there's friction, sometimes there's things that just aren't quite aligning. And you can't see clearly what's actually happening when you're wrapped up in a situation, but a therapist can.|||可能会存在一些问题，这些问题确实会对我们的心理健康产生影响。也许是与你的亲密伴侣、与你的家人、与你的朋友，人际关系在情感上确实非常复杂。有时会有摩擦，有时有些事情就是无法达成一致。当你深陷某种情境时，你无法看清到底发生了什么，但治疗师可以。
They're not involved. They can provide that objectivity that is really needed and kind of clear the path for healthy growth, healthy conversations, decision making, boundary setting, regardless of your relationship with someone. You know, there is a reason that relationship therapists exist. Our relationships are a huge, huge part of our identity and of our lives, and they really do work, and you don't always need to go with the other person in question.
They're not involved. They can provide that objectivity that is really needed and kind of clear the path for healthy growth, healthy conversations, decision making, boundary setting, regardless of your relationship with someone. You know, there is a reason that relationship therapists exist. Our relationships are a huge, huge part of our identity and of our lives, and they really do work, and you don't always need to go with the other person in question.|||他们没有卷入其中。他们能够提供非常需要的客观性，并为健康成长、健康对话、决策、设定边界扫清道路，无论你与某人的关系如何。你知道，关系治疗师的存在是有原因的。我们的人际关系是我们身份认同和生活中极其重要的一部分，它们确实发挥作用，而且你并不总是需要和当事的另一个人一起去。
You can go by yourself. You can learn some really valuable strategies for communication and balance. boundary setting and anything else that's on your mind. So I would highly, highly recommend. And finally, you should be thinking about therapy if you just need a check-in. You just want to assess how you're going, get some mental clarity, you know, for maintenance rather than repairs. Therapy is still for you in those situations. I think a massive misconception surrounding psychological assistance and help is that you have to be absolutely suffering. at the lowest point in your life with something really serious in order to get guidance and to get
You can go by yourself. You can learn some really valuable strategies for communication and balance. boundary setting and anything else that's on your mind. So I would highly, highly recommend. And finally, you should be thinking about therapy if you just need a check-in. You just want to assess how you're going, get some mental clarity, you know, for maintenance rather than repairs. Therapy is still for you in those situations. I think a massive misconception surrounding psychological assistance and help is that you have to be absolutely suffering. at the lowest point in your life with something really serious in order to get guidance and to get|||你可以自己去。你可以学到一些非常宝贵的关于沟通和平衡的策略。设定边界以及你心中的任何其他事情。所以我强烈、强烈推荐。最后，如果你只是需要做一次心理状态检视，你也应该考虑进行心理治疗。你只是想评估一下自己最近过得怎么样，获得一些心灵上的清晰感，你知道，这是为了日常维护而不是出了故障才去修理。在那种情况下，心理治疗依然适合你。我认为围绕心理援助和帮助的一个巨大误区是，你必须正在饱受折磨。处于人生最低谷并遭遇非常严重的事情，才能获得指导和
help. And that is absolutely not true. You can always go if you're just feeling a bit off or you want to better understand how you're actually going. The way I always explain this to people is that we have our annual doctor checkups. We go to the dentist once every three years or so. I don't know if that's accurate because I really hate the dentist, but that's beside the point. in every other area of our health. It is recommended that we have a checkup periodically. And our psychological health should be treated exactly the same way, maintenance rather than repairs.
help. And that is absolutely not true. You can always go if you're just feeling a bit off or you want to better understand how you're actually going. The way I always explain this to people is that we have our annual doctor checkups. We go to the dentist once every three years or so. I don't know if that's accurate because I really hate the dentist, but that's beside the point. in every other area of our health. It is recommended that we have a checkup periodically. And our psychological health should be treated exactly the same way, maintenance rather than repairs.|||帮助。这绝对不是真的。如果你只是感觉状态有点不对劲，或者你想更好地了解自己目前的真实状况，你随时都可以去。我向人们解释这一点的方式总是：我们每年都要做医生体检。我们大约每三年去一次牙医诊所。我不知道这准不准确，因为我真的很讨厌看牙医，但这不是重点。在我们健康的每一个其他领域。我们都被建议定期进行体检。我们的心理健康也应该受到完全相同的对待，重在日常维护而非事后修理。
It could also save you a lot of time and worry in the future to just check in with yourself alongside a licensed professional and see how you're going. Once you know that therapy or seeing a psychologist is something that you need, the next steps are often a bit complicated or they will seem that way because the level of accurate and consistent communication is really confusing. I think that's where a lot of us will get stuck. We know that we need help. We know that we want help. But where to from there? Well, that's what we're here for, you know? So let's run through the steps together to make
It could also save you a lot of time and worry in the future to just check in with yourself alongside a licensed professional and see how you're going. Once you know that therapy or seeing a psychologist is something that you need, the next steps are often a bit complicated or they will seem that way because the level of accurate and consistent communication is really confusing. I think that's where a lot of us will get stuck. We know that we need help. We know that we want help. But where to from there? Well, that's what we're here for, you know? So let's run through the steps together to make|||在持证专业人士的陪伴下对自己进行一次心理状态检视，看看自己过得怎么样，也能在未来为你节省大量的时间和担忧。一旦你知道心理治疗或看心理医生是你所需要的，接下来的步骤通常会有点复杂，或者看起来很复杂，因为准确且持续的沟通水平真的很令人困惑。我想这也是我们许多人会卡壳的地方。我们知道我们需要帮助。我们知道我们想要帮助。但接下来该怎么办呢？嗯，这就是我们来到这里的意义，你知道的？所以让我们一起梳理这些步骤，让
it a little bit easier. If you're in Australia, like myself, the first step is to go to your GP, your local doctor, and get a mental health care plan. Make sure to book a long appointment if your GP requires you to, compared to a short appointment, because this will give them the necessary time to get a plan written up and talk you through the process. When you are there, your GP or your doctor, and this is the case wherever you are in the world, if you're looking to be referred into psychological support services. They'll normally ask you to complete some kind of questionnaire. The most typical one is called the K-10. It's a simple series of questions to measure your level of psychological distress. It doesn't take long. There are no wrong answers. And it will
it a little bit easier. If you're in Australia, like myself, the first step is to go to your GP, your local doctor, and get a mental health care plan. Make sure to book a long appointment if your GP requires you to, compared to a short appointment, because this will give them the necessary time to get a plan written up and talk you through the process. When you are there, your GP or your doctor, and this is the case wherever you are in the world, if you're looking to be referred into psychological support services. They'll normally ask you to complete some kind of questionnaire. The most typical one is called the K-10. It's a simple series of questions to measure your level of psychological distress. It doesn't take long. There are no wrong answers. And it will|||事情变得稍微容易一些。如果你和笔者一样在澳大利亚，第一步就是去找你的全科医生（GP），也就是当地的医生，获取一份心理健康护理计划。如果你的全科医生要求，与短预约相比，务必预约一个长一点的时间段，因为这会给他们必要的时间来起草计划并向你详细讲解整个过程。当你去到那里时，你的全科医生或医生——无论你身处世界何地，只要你希望被转诊到心理支持服务机构，情况都是如此——通常会要求你完成某种问卷调查。最典型的问卷被称为 K-10 量表。这是一系列用来衡量你的心理痛苦程度的简单问题。它不需要花很长时间。没有错误的答案。而且它会
ask you questions such as, how often do you feel tired for no good reason? Or in the past four weeks, how often did you feel nervous, how often did you feel depressed, worthless, all kind of on that theme. And given your score, your doctors will be able to kind of see how you're going and give you a mental health care plan. And this plan immediately provides you with a subsidized or discounted rate for 10 sessions a year with a licensed psychologist. And they can even give you recommendations or a referral to a specific person if you ask them to, and someone in your local area. Or you know, you can always ask your friends for some recommendations. I promise a few of them will probably already be in therapy.
ask you questions such as, how often do you feel tired for no good reason? Or in the past four weeks, how often did you feel nervous, how often did you feel depressed, worthless, all kind of on that theme. And given your score, your doctors will be able to kind of see how you're going and give you a mental health care plan. And this plan immediately provides you with a subsidized or discounted rate for 10 sessions a year with a licensed psychologist. And they can even give you recommendations or a referral to a specific person if you ask them to, and someone in your local area. Or you know, you can always ask your friends for some recommendations. I promise a few of them will probably already be in therapy.|||问你一些这样的问题，例如：你多久会无缘无故地感到疲惫？或者在过去的四周里，你多久感到紧张一次，多久感到抑郁、毫无价值，大致都是这个主题。根据你的得分，你的医生将能够大致了解你的情况，并为你提供一份心理健康护理计划。这份计划会立即为你提供与持证心理学家每年 10 次治疗的补贴或打折费率。如果你要求的话，他们甚至可以为你推荐特定的人选或提供转诊，比如你当地的人。或者你知道的，你随时可以向你的朋友寻求一些推荐。我保证他们当中肯定已经有几个人在接受心理治疗了。
And they might know someone really lovely or know someone else who knows someone who can provide you with the assistance that you're needing. And it also opens a really healthy conversation, which I think is just, you know, a bonus. If you are in the US, the UK, Canada, New Zealand, wherever you are in the world, the first few steps that I just outlined are essentially the same. However, without the subsidised care and 10 free sessions, which as far as I know is exclusive to Australia, but there are other alternatives in other countries.
And they might know someone really lovely or know someone else who knows someone who can provide you with the assistance that you're needing. And it also opens a really healthy conversation, which I think is just, you know, a bonus. If you are in the US, the UK, Canada, New Zealand, wherever you are in the world, the first few steps that I just outlined are essentially the same. However, without the subsidised care and 10 free sessions, which as far as I know is exclusive to Australia, but there are other alternatives in other countries.|||他们可能会认识某个非常可爱的人，或者认识其他人，而那个人又认识能为你提供所需帮助的人。这也开启了一场非常健康的对话，我认为这简直就是（你知道的）一个额外的好处。如果你在美国、英国、加拿大、新西兰，或者世界上的任何地方，我刚才概述的前几个步骤基本上都是一样的。然而，并没有补贴护理和 10 次免费治疗，据我所知，这是澳大利亚独有的，但在其他国家有其他的替代方案。
The first stop, though, is always talking to a doctor or another medical professional who is appropriate for the situation. they can often direct you to someone who can help or they'll provide referrals for cheaper or even subsidized services. If you are in New Zealand or the UK, you can access some therapies for free. So if in New Zealand, I think that includes various mental health services that are provided by the government and in the UK all talking therapies, which is what we would typically think of when we think of therapy, they're actually free under the NHS. And in the US, you can actually go to federally qualified health centers
The first stop, though, is always talking to a doctor or another medical professional who is appropriate for the situation. they can often direct you to someone who can help or they'll provide referrals for cheaper or even subsidized services. If you are in New Zealand or the UK, you can access some therapies for free. So if in New Zealand, I think that includes various mental health services that are provided by the government and in the UK all talking therapies, which is what we would typically think of when we think of therapy, they're actually free under the NHS. And in the US, you can actually go to federally qualified health centers|||不过，第一站总是与医生或适合这种情况的其他医疗专业人员交谈。他们通常可以把你引荐给能够提供帮助的人，或者他们会为更便宜甚至有补贴的服务提供转诊。如果你在新西兰或英国，你可以免费获得一些心理治疗。所以如果在纽西兰，我认为这包括政府提供的各种心理健康服务，而在英国，所有的谈话治疗——也就是我们通常一想到心理治疗时所想到的那种——在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）下其实都是免费的。在美国，你实际上可以去联邦资格认证健康中心
or check with your insurance provider to see if some kind of psychological assistance is covered. If it's not, there are always options. There are so many free services out there. But as always, the first stop is your local family doctor. They're going to probably initially ask you some questions or administer a mental health test to kind of get an eye. idea of what you're going through before referring you to a specialist, including a counselor or a psychologist or even a psychiatrist, depending on the severity of what you're going through.
or check with your insurance provider to see if some kind of psychological assistance is covered. If it's not, there are always options. There are so many free services out there. But as always, the first stop is your local family doctor. They're going to probably initially ask you some questions or administer a mental health test to kind of get an eye. idea of what you're going through before referring you to a specialist, including a counselor or a psychologist or even a psychiatrist, depending on the severity of what you're going through.|||或者向你的保险公司查询，看看某种心理援助是否在报销范围内。如果没有，也总有其他的选择。外面有太多的免费服务。但一如既往，第一站是你当地的家庭医生。他们可能会首先问你一些问题，或者进行一次心理健康测试，以便对你的经历有个大概的了解。在把你转诊给专科医生之前，包括咨询师、心理学家甚至精神科医生，这取决于你所经历的事情的严重程度。
There are also worldwide online services like Talkspace or BetterHelp, neither of which are sponsoring this episode. And full disclaimer, I've never personally used either of these services, but they do really promote affordable, accessible online therapy. And I've heard other people who have had really amazing experiences. So it may be something to check out, especially because it is often much cheaper. But if in-person therapy is more your thing, there are so many directories and guides online and online resources that you can use. In the US, there's this one called the psychologist locator or the therapist directory and it can help you find someone in your local area based on your specific needs. I would also highly recommend this resource to anyone who
There are also worldwide online services like Talkspace or BetterHelp, neither of which are sponsoring this episode. And full disclaimer, I've never personally used either of these services, but they do really promote affordable, accessible online therapy. And I've other people who have had really amazing experiences. So it may be something to check out, especially because it is often much cheaper. But if in-person therapy is more your thing, there are so many directories and guides online and online resources that you can use. In the US, there's this one called the psychologist locator or the therapist directory and it can help you find someone in your local area based on your specific needs. I would also highly recommend this resource to anyone who|||还有诸如 Talkspace 或 BetterHelp 这样的全球在线服务，这两家都没有赞助本期节目。在此发表完全免责声明，我从未亲自使用过这两项服务，但它们确实在推广价格实惠、易于获取的在线心理治疗。而且我也有过其他拥有非常棒体验的朋友。所以这或许是一个值得了解的选择，特别是由于它通常要便宜得多. 但如果你更喜欢线下面对面治疗，网上有大量的目录、指南和在线资源供你使用。在美国，有一个叫做“心理学家定位器”或“治疗师名录”的工具，它可以根据你的具体需求帮你找到当地合适的人选。我也强烈向任何人推荐这个资源，
was searching for the right person to speak to, Healthline. It's a really amazing website that I've come across and they have an article called Therapy for Every Budget, How to Access It. And it's amazing as kind of a navigational portal for finding the most appropriate help for you and your circumstances. But before you jump right on board with the first person who was suggested to you or the first person that you meet with, it's really important to identify exactly what the core issue is or the primary reason you're accessing therapy in the first place, because this will really determine who you go to for a couple of reasons. I've been to. to therapy multiple times across my life. I've taken breaks. I've returned. I've found new
was searching for the right person to speak to, Healthline. It's a really amazing website that I've come across and they have an article called Therapy for Every Budget, How to Access It. And it's amazing as kind of a navigational portal for finding the most appropriate help for you and your circumstances. But before you jump right on board with the first person who was suggested to you or the first person that you meet with, it's really important to identify exactly what the core issue is or the primary reason you're accessing therapy in the first place, because this will really determine who you go to for a couple of reasons. I've been to.|||正在寻找合适倾诉对象的人，那就是 Healthline。这是我遇到过的一个非常棒的网站，他们有一篇文章叫《适合各种预算的心理治疗：如何获得》。它作为一个导航门户网站，非常出色，能帮你找到最适合你和你的情况的帮助。但在你盲目接受别人向你推荐的第一个人或你遇到的第一个人之前，非常重要的是要明确核心问题到底是什么，或者你最初接受心理治疗的主要原因是什么，因为这确实会由于几个原因决定你去找谁。我去过。
therapists for new problems, for new issues. But there are some core things that I look out for and tend to notice when I am selecting a therapist. And I really want to be careful about who I'm speaking to because I know that there is an important relationship built on trust and being vulnerable that needs to develop in order for therapy to be effective. The things I always look for are someone who has at least three years of experience. They need to be a registered psychologist, someone I feel comfortable with, who specializes in my chosen therapy, and ideally has previous experience in what I want to talk about,
to therapy multiple times across my life. I've taken breaks. I've returned. I've found new therapists for new problems, for new issues. But there are some core things that I look out for and tend to notice when I am selecting a therapist. And I really want to be careful about who I'm speaking to because I know that there is an important relationship built on trust and being vulnerable that needs to develop in order for therapy to be effective. The things I always look for are someone who has at least three years of experience. They need to be a registered psychologist, someone I feel comfortable with, who specializes in my chosen therapy, and ideally has previous experience in what I want to talk about,|||我的人生中经历过多次心理治疗。我曾暂停过。我曾回归过。我曾为新的问题、新的状况寻找过新的治疗师。但我在选择治疗师时，确实有一些核心的关注点和倾向于注意的事项。我真的想对和我交谈的人保持谨慎，因为我知道，为了让治疗发挥作用，需要建立一种建立在信任和展现脆弱之上的重要关系。我一直在寻找的条件是：至少有三年经验的人。他们必须是注册心理学家，一个让我感到自在的人，擅长我所选择的治疗方法，并且理想情况下在我想谈论的领域有先前的经验，
although I would say that most professionals will likely have seen someone else like you with a similar issue as you if they've been around for a while. And I also make sure that it's in an environment or location that is accessible for me. You know, sometimes after therapy, you're going to feel really emotionally exhausted and a one-hour commute home isn't going to be what you need. Obviously, some of these things are a luxury, but choosing a therapist is kind of like dating sometimes. you need to have your non-negotiables to get what you want from the relationship and choose the right person
although I would say that most professionals will likely have seen someone else like you with a similar issue as you if they've been around for a while. And I also make sure that it's in an environment or location that is accessible for me. You know, sometimes after therapy, you're going to feel really emotionally exhausted and a one-hour commute home isn't going to be what you need. Obviously, some of these things are a luxury, but choosing a therapist is kind of like dating sometimes. you need to have your non-negotiables to get what you want from the relationship and choose the right person|||尽管我想说，如果大多数专业人士从业了一段时间，他们很可能已经接待过其他像你一样、有着与你相似问题的人。而且我还会确保它处于一个对我来说交通便利的环境或地点。你知道，有时在心理治疗结束后，你的情绪会感到非常疲惫，花一个小时通勤回家绝不是你所需要的。很显然，其中有些事情是一种奢侈，但选择治疗师有时有点像约会。你必须有你的底线（非妥协原则），才能从这段关系中得到你想要的，并选择合适的人，
and sometimes you're going to have to see a couple of them just to make sure you know what you want. But I want to break down some of these distinctive qualities or differences a little bit more. Firstly, when I say I want a registered psychologist, there is an important and crucial difference between a psychologist and a therapist or a counselor. So terms like counsellor, therapist, psychologist, they're often used very interchangeably, but there is a distinction. So in most countries, to call yourself a psychologist, you have to have gone through some fairly strict requirements and training and often involves some level of graduate study, like a master's degree, and more than six years of specialized study, whereas counselling is a lot less
and sometimes you're going to have to see a couple of them just to make sure you know what you want. But I want to break down some of these distinctive qualities or differences a little bit more. Firstly, when I say I want a registered psychologist, there is an important and crucial difference between a psychologist and a therapist or a counselor. So terms like counsellor, therapist, psychologist, they're often used very interchangeably, but there is a distinction. So in most countries, to call yourself a psychologist, you have to have gone through some fairly strict requirements and training and often involves some level of graduate study, like a master's degree, and more than six years of specialized study, whereas counselling is a lot less|||有时你可能不得不见几个人，只是为了确保你知道自己想要什么。但我还想更详细地剖析其中一些独特的品质或区别。首先，当我说我想要一个注册心理学家时，心理学家与治疗师或咨询师之间存在着一个重要且关键的区别。因此，“咨询师”、“治疗师”、“心理学家”这些术语经常被交替使用，但它们之间确实存在区别。所以在大多数国家，要想称自己为心理学家，你必须经历一些相当严格的要求和培训，通常涉及一定程度的研究生学习，比如硕士学位，以及超过六年的专门学习，而咨询则要少得多
regulated, but still super useful and valuable. It just involves less formal education. So I know that in Australia, counselling is kind of what we would call a self-regulated profession, but it doesn't mean they haven't done some form of training and that they don't have the valuable skills and ability to offer the necessary support, the compassion, the safe space for you. Psychologists, however, they're able to administer certain therapies that include a specific evidence base and training, such as cognitive behavioral therapy, and they tend to have had more time and training to develop their skills. Psychiatrists, they are a whole other ballgame, but they're also one that we often hear about. These are essentially specialist doctors.
regulated, but still super useful and valuable. It just involves less formal education. So I know that in Australia, counselling is kind of what we would call a self-regulated profession, but it doesn't mean they haven't done some form of training and that they don't have the valuable skills and ability to offer the necessary support, the compassion, the safe space for you. Psychologists, however, they're able to administer certain therapies that include a specific evidence base and training, such as cognitive behavioral therapy, and they tend to have had more time and training to develop their skills. Psychiatrists, they are a whole other ballgame, but they're also one that we often hear about. These are essentially specialist doctors.|||受到监管，但仍然超级有用且有价值。它只是涉及较少的正规教育。所以我知道在澳大利亚，咨询在某种程度上是我们所说的自我监管行业，但这并不意味着他们没有接受过某种形式的培训，也不意味着他们不具备宝贵的技能和能力来为你提供必要的支持、同情和安全的空间。然而，心理学家能够实施某些包含特定循证基础和培训的疗法，例如认知行为疗法，并且他们往往拥有更多的时间和培训来发展他们的技能。精神科医生，那是完全不同的另一码事，但这也是我们经常听到的一类人。他们本质上是专科医生。
They go through the same amount of training as, say, an emergency room doctor or a surgeon, and the distinction here is that they can provide prescriptions for certain medications, and they can often offer a formal diagnosis for conditions like ADHD or schizophrenia. They are also normally a lot less available than a counselor or a psychologist, just given the nature of the amount of training they need to do, and they typically have longer wait lists than we would already expect with most mental health professionals. So something to note, but that doesn't mean. that you should not be looking for someone if that's who you need. And aside from all of those
They go through the same amount of training as, say, an emergency room doctor or a surgeon, and the distinction here is that they can provide prescriptions for certain medications, and they can often offer a formal diagnosis for conditions like ADHD or schizophrenia. They are also normally a lot less available than a counselor or a psychologist, just given the nature of the amount of training they need to do, and they typically have longer wait lists than we would already expect with most mental health professionals. So something to note, but that doesn't mean. that you should not be looking for someone if that's who you need. And aside from all of those|||他们经历的培训量与急诊室医生或外科医生相当，这里的区别在于他们可以为某些药物开处方，并且他们通常可以为诸如多动症（ADHD）或精神分裂症等状况提供正式诊断。考虑到他们需要进行的培训量，他们的可预约性通常也远低于咨询师或心理学家，并且与我们对大多数心理健康专业人士的预期相比，他们的预约名单通常要长得多。所以这是需要注意的一点，但这并不意味着。如果你需要的就是这样的人，你就不应该去寻找他们。抛开所有这些
details, whichever path you do choose to take, whichever is best for you, which suits your budget, which suits your location, which suits your needs, it's important to note that any mental health professional, specifically psychologists and therapists, they're going to do different things and offer different kinds of help. They're a specialist who focus mainly on complex family trauma or eating disorders, personality disorders, anxiety, sexual trauma, anything you can think of. And one way that you can make that distinction or choose the right person is based on the type of therapy that they offer. And they'll often list in their online profiles or bio exactly what their specialties are, be that children and adolescents,
details, whichever path you do choose to take, whichever is best for you, which suits your budget, which suits your location, which suits your needs, it's important to note that any mental health professional, specifically psychologists and therapists, they're going to do different things and offer different kinds of help. They're a specialist who focus mainly on complex family trauma or eating disorders, personality disorders, anxiety, sexual trauma, anything you can think of. And one way that you can make that distinction or choose the right person is based on the type of therapy that they offer. And they'll often list in their online profiles or bio exactly what their specialties are, be that children and adolescents,|||细节不谈，无论你最终选择哪条路，哪条路最适合你，最符合你的预算，最符合你的地点，最符合你的需求，需要注意的是，任何心理健康专业人士，特别是心理学家和治疗师，他们做的事情不同，提供的帮助类型也不同。他们是主要专注于复杂家庭创伤或饮食失调、人格障碍、焦虑、性创伤以及你能想到的任何事情的专家. 你做出区分或选择合适人选的方法之一，是基于他们提供的心理治疗类型。他们通常会在其在线个人资料或简介中列出他们的专长到底是什么，无论是儿童和青少年，
bereavement and grief or relationship therapy. There are also minimal. millions of different types of therapy options. Maybe not millions, thousands, hundreds. But I'm going to focus on the major ones that you will often come across in your search. And then kind of mention some of the more interesting or different kinds of therapy. So I want to kind of list these and give a bit of a description of the major ones. So you can kind of identify which one might suit your needs at the moment. the first and perhaps the most widespread form of therapy for issues like depression, anxiety, drug and alcohol problems or eating disorders.
bereavement and grief or relationship therapy. There are also minimal. millions of different types of therapy options. Maybe not millions, thousands, hundreds. But I'm going to focus on the major ones that you will often come your search. And then kind of mention some of the more interesting or different kinds of therapy. So I want to kind of list these and give a bit of a description of the major ones. So you can kind of identify which one might suit your needs at the moment. the first and perhaps the most widespread form of therapy for issues like depression, anxiety, drug and alcohol problems or eating disorders.|||丧亲和悲伤还是关系治疗。还有极少数的。数百万种不同类型的治疗选择。也许不是数百万，是成千上万，数百种。但我将专注于你在搜索中经常遇到那些主要类型。然后顺便提及一些更有趣或不同种类的心理治疗。所以我想把这些列出来，并对主要的几种做一点描述。这样你就可以大致辨别哪一种可能适合你目前的需要。第一种，也是针对抑郁症、焦虑症、毒品和酒精问题或饮食失调等问题最普遍的心理治疗形式，
It's called cognitive behavioral therapy or CBT, as it's known. And it seeks to produce important psychological changes by addressing our unhealthy thought patterns. This involves mental training, essentially, to recognize unhealthy thought patterns in cognitive, distortions and therefore gain a better understanding of the reasons behind your behaviors. This kind of therapy really helps you build your problem solving skills, to deal with difficult situations, to deal with trauma, things like learning how to use meditation, learning how to calm your mind, and how to face your fears over time and develop a deeper sense of confidence in your own abilities.
It's called cognitive behavioral therapy or CBT, as it's known. And it seeks to produce important psychological changes by addressing our unhealthy thought patterns. This involves mental training, essentially, to recognize unhealthy thought patterns in cognitive, distortions and therefore gain a better understanding of the reasons behind your behaviors. This kind of therapy really helps you build your problem solving skills, to deal with difficult situations, to deal with trauma, things like learning how to use meditation, learning how to calm your mind, and how to face your fears over time and develop a deeper sense of confidence in your own abilities.|||被称为认知行为疗法（CBT）。它旨在通过解决我们不健康的思维模式来产生重要的心理变化。这本质上涉及心理训练，以识别认知中的不健康思维模式、认知扭曲，从而更好地理解你行为背后的原因。这种治疗真的能帮助你培养解决问题的能力，应对困难情况，应对创伤，比如学习如何使用冥想，学习如何让你的心灵平静下来，以及随着时间的推移如何面对你的恐惧，并对你自己的能力建立更深层次的自信。
The evidence behind this therapy is endless. Endless. I would not have time to cover all the articles and research, but just trust me, it's one of the most researched and practice ways to change your thoughts and therefore your behavioral patterns in response to mental distress, and I would guarantee it's probably available in most places. The next is called dialectical behavior therapy. it's actually a modified version of CBT, and it's also fairly common.
The evidence behind this therapy is endless. Endless. I would not have time to cover all the articles and research, but just trust me, it's one of the most researched and practice ways to change your thoughts and therefore your behavioral patterns in response to mental distress, and I would guarantee it's probably available in most places. The next is called dialectical behavior therapy. it's actually a modified version of CBT, and it's also fairly common.|||支持这种疗法的证据数不胜数。数不胜数。我没有时间涵盖所有的文章和研究，但请相信我，它是研究最多、实践最多的方法之一，可以改变你的想法，从而改变你的行为模式以应对精神痛苦，我敢保证它在大多数地方大概都能找到。下一个被称为辩证行为疗法。它实际上是 CBT 的修改版本，也相当常见。
It's colloquially known as talking therapy, which is not to say that the other kinds of therapy don't also have a fair amount of talking involved, but DBT in particular stresses that we should process our emotions and our experiences by firstly verbalising them to help regulate our future emotional reactions through a number of strategies. It can help people who have difficulty with emotional regulation or who are exhibiting self-destructive behaviors, and it helps you manage your emotions by teaching you skills to cope with day-to-day life and find new behaviors to replace harmful ones. It helps you understand exactly why you struggle with the things that you do through psychoeducation, and then also relies on that strong relationship between you and your therapist or,
It's colloquially known as talking therapy, which is not to say that the other kinds of therapy don't also have a fair amount of talking involved, but DBT in particular stresses that we should process our emotions and our experiences by firstly verbalising them to help regulate our future emotional reactions through a number of strategies. It can help people who have difficulty with emotional regulation or who are exhibiting self-destructive behaviors, and it helps you manage your emotions by teaching you skills to cope with day-to-day life and find new behaviors to replace harmful ones. It helps you understand exactly why you struggle with the things that you do through psychoeducation, and then also relies on that strong relationship between you and your therapist or,|||它俗称谈话疗法，这并不是说其他种类的心理治疗不涉及大量的谈话，但辩证行为疗法（DBT）特别强调，我们应该通过首先将情绪和体验语言化来处理它们，从而通过多种策略帮助调节我们未来的情绪反应。它可以帮助那些在情绪调节上有困难或表现出自我毁灭行为的人，它通过教你应对日常生活技能并寻找新行为来替代有害行为，从而帮助你管理情绪。它通过心理教育帮助你准确理解为什么你在所做的事情上苦苦挣扎，然后还依赖于你与治疗师或心理学家之间那种牢固的关系，
psychologist to help build up those skills, build up that distress tolerance, build up that emotional regulation and that mindfulness. The next is psychotherapy. It's also called psychodynamic therapy. And I would assume that this is what we would typically think of when we think of seeing a counselor or a psychologist. You know, picture the very Freudian method of laying on a couch and having someone interpret your dream. dreams or interpret your paintings or your drawings. This type of therapy, it really focuses on self-awareness. It focuses on self-examination and self-reflection.
psychologist to help build up those skills, build up that distress tolerance, build up that emotional regulation and that mindfulness. The next is psychotherapy. It's also called psychodynamic therapy. And I would assume that this is what we would typically think of when we think of seeing a counselor or a psychologist. You know, picture the very Freudian method of laying on a couch and having someone interpret your dream. dreams or interpret your paintings or your drawings. This type of therapy, it really focuses on self-awareness. It focuses on self-examination and self-reflection.|||心理学家来帮助培养这些技能，建立痛苦耐受力，建立情绪调节和正念。下一个是心理动力学疗法。它也被称为精神动力学疗法。我想这正是我们通常在想到去看咨询师或心理学家时所想到的。你知道的，想象一下非常弗洛伊德式的躺在沙发上让人解释你的梦境的方法。梦想或解释你的画作或绘画。这种类型的治疗，它真正关注的是自我意识。它专注于自我审视和自我反思。
So if you do choose this type of therapy, what you'll normally find is that whoever you've chosen to or enlisted to help you, whatever mental health professional you've gone to, they will help guide you towards identifying the root cause of any suffering or problematic behaviors, by examining your past to understand the present. So it's really about going back into your childhood, going back into critical events in your life or critical periods, and identifying where is that turning point, where is the root of the experiences you are now having?
So if you do choose this type of therapy, what you'll normally find is that whoever you've chosen to or enlisted to help you, whatever mental health professional you've gone to, they will help guide you towards identifying the root cause of any suffering or problematic behaviors, by examining your past to understand the present. So it's really about going back into your childhood, going back into critical events in your life or critical periods, and identifying where is that turning point, where is the root of the experiences you are now having?|||因此，如果你确实选择了这种类型的治疗，你通常会发现，无论你选择或招募谁来帮助你，无论你去找哪个心理健康专业人士，他们都会通过检查你的过去来理解现在，从而帮助引导你找出任何痛苦或问题行为的根本原因。所以这实际上是关于回到你的童年，回到你生活中的关键事件或关键时期，并找出那个转折点在哪里，你现在所经历的体验的根源在哪里？
And it can be applied to a wide range of psychological disorders, things like anxiety is a big one, OCD, eating disorders, it's really endless. So I'm going to run through some of the others fairly quickly, but they are worth a bit more of a deep dive if they perk your interest. Exposure therapy, I personally actually use this. I do this right now with my current therapist. And it's mainly used for treating phobias,
它可以应用于广泛的心理障碍，比如焦虑症就是一个大类别，强迫症、进食障碍，真的是无穷无尽。所以我打算比较快地过一下其中一些其他的疗法，但如果你对它们感兴趣的话，还是很值得深入了解的。暴露疗法，我自己其实就在用。我现在就在和目前的治疗师一起做这个。它主要用于治疗恐惧症，
but some other things as well, through gradually exposing someone to triggering situations, whilst kind of also applying mindfulness techniques so that it gradually makes you feel more comfortable with the fear, more comfortable with the discomfort that your trigger item or object or event brings you. So like I said, I use this with my claustrophobia. Essentially, what will normally happen is they will create almost like a table or a ladder of things that are really triggering for you that are all aligned to the same event
以及其他一些问题，通过让某人逐渐接触触发情境，同时配合运用正念技巧，让你逐渐适应这种恐惧，更能适应触发你的物品、对象或事件所带来的不适感。就像我说的，我的幽闭恐惧症就在用这个方法。基本上，通常的做法是，他们会列出一个表格或建立一个阶梯，把对你来说真正具有触发性的事情都按同一事件
or the same object. And you slowly work your way up the ladder until you can address. and be in the situation that you most fear. The next one is a little bit weird. I've heard about this before. I've never used it, but I do know people that do. It's called eye movement desensitization and reprocessing therapy. Sounds really weird, right?
或同一对象排列好。然后你慢慢地顺着这个阶梯往上走，直到你能应对并处于你最恐惧的情境中。下一个有点奇怪。我以前听说过这个。我从没用过，但我确实知道有人在用。它叫做眼动脱敏再处理疗法。听起来真的很奇怪，对吧？
You know, like what do our eyes have to do with our mental health? But it's a method that really helps reduce the distress associated with certain and specific traumatic events or memories. So essentially how it works is your therapist will move their fingers back and forth in front of your eyes and ask you to follow some kind of motion or sound whilst you recall a disturbing event. And gradually, the therapist will guide you to shift your thoughts in that moment to pleasant ones. It's not as common as some of the others, but essentially what it attempts to do is to reduce a traumatic response or an intense response. response to a traumatic memory by changing how these memories are stored in the brain through altering the way our brain cells and our synaptic connections communicate in the presence of a
你知道的，我们的眼睛和我们的心理健康有什么关系？但这是一种确实有助于减轻与某些特定创伤事件或记忆相关的痛苦的方法。所以它的大致工作原理是：你的治疗师会在你的眼前来回移动手指，并要求你跟随某种动作或声音，同时你回忆一件令人不安的事件。渐渐地，治疗师会引导你在那一刻将思绪转移到愉快的事情上。它不像其他一些疗法那么常见，但它试图做的是通过改变这些记忆在大脑中的储存方式——也就是在出现创伤记忆时改变我们脑细胞和突触连接的交流方式——来减少对创伤记忆的创伤反应或强烈反应。
traumatic memory. So essentially that movement that we're talking about, it's meant to almost rewire your brain whilst you're in the presence of that traumatic memory. Would really, really recommend looking into it. It's really fascinating. It's really new. So go for your life. The final really common one that I really want to address as well is called interpersonal therapy. As the name kind of explains, it focuses on addressing problems in our relationships with others that are impacting our mental health. That might be dealing with grief. It might be unresolved conflict and trauma in your parental relationships. It can really help with transitions like divorce or a serious breakup or just helping us manage our relationships. So those are the most common types of therapy that
所以基本上我们谈到的那种眼球运动，它的目的就是在你处于该创伤记忆中时，几乎是重新连接你的大脑。真的非常非常推荐去了解一下。它真的很迷人。而且它非常新，所以大家尽管去探索吧。最后一种我也很想探讨的非常普遍的疗法叫做人际心理疗法。正如这个名字所解释的，它专注于解决我们与他人关系中影响我们心理健康的问题。这可能包括处理悲伤。它可能是父母关系中未解决的冲突和创伤。它对离婚或严重分手等人生转变真的很有帮助，或者只是帮我们管理好人际关系。所以这些是最常见的疗法类型，
you might find if you go to a psychologist or a particular clinic. But make sure you ask what exact therapies they offer. You don't want to rock up and be like, I really want to do cognitive behavioral therapy and it's not available. So do kind of do your research. There are some other really fun ones, not really fun, but interesting and kind of niche therapies that I've heard of before. I thought I would share things like hypnotherapy, expressive arts therapy, dance therapy, sand play therapy, compassion focus therapy, and many others. They're a bit alternative, but they can be really highly effective for some people. I did art therapy for a while back in 2019, and it honestly had such an impact on me. Anytime I find myself kind of spiraling or struggling these days,
如果你去找心理学家或某个诊所，你可能会遇到这些。但一定要问清楚他们提供具体哪些疗法。你可不想兴冲冲地跑去说“我真的想做认知行为疗法”，结果这里根本没有。所以还是要做好研究。还有一些其他非常有趣的——其实算不上有趣，但很有意思且比较小众的疗法，我以前听说过。我想顺便分享一下，比如催眠疗法、表达性艺术疗法、舞蹈疗法、沙盘游戏疗法、慈悲焦点疗法以及许多其他疗法。它们有点非主流，但对某些人来说可能非常有效。我在2019年做过一段时间的艺术疗法，它真的对我产生了很大的影响。如今每当我发现自己情绪陷入恶性循环或苦苦挣扎时，
I know that reconnecting with my creativity will 100% make me feel better. So have a look into it, if any of those are particularly interesting. Like I said, not every psychologist or therapist is going to offer all of these kinds of therapy, especially some of the more specific ones like sand play therapy. I would say the majority of therapists are not doing that on their day to day. But the common ones like CBT, like DBT, like exposure therapy, you'll find in most places and at most practices.
我知道重新连接我的创造力100%能让我感觉好受一些。所以如果其中任何一种引起了你的特别兴趣，不妨去了解一下。就像我说的，并不是每个心理学家或治疗师都会提供所有这些疗法，尤其是像沙盘游戏疗法这样更具体的一些疗法。我想大多数治疗师日常工作中是不会做这个的。但那些常见的疗法，比如CBT（认知行为疗法）、DBT（辩证行为疗法）、暴露疗法，你在大多数地方和大多数诊所都能找到。
But this kind of leads back to the point we raised before, is that not every therapist is going to be the right fit for you, even if they've done all the training, even if they're really experienced. Don't be afraid to try out a few different places before you find the right one. You want to be able to be vulnerable with someone and feel comfortable. And that's not going to happen if you and that other person just don't get along. You know, a therapist, a psychologist, they're a person as well. They have certain ways of communicating, certain ways of framing problems.
但这其实又回到了我们之前提出的观点：并不是每个治疗师都绝对适合你，即使他们做过所有的培训，即使他们经验非常丰富。在找到对的人之前，不要害怕尝试几个不同的地方。你需要能够在一个人的面前展现脆弱并感到舒适。如果你和另一个人根本合不来，这是不可能实现的。你知道的，治疗师、心理学家，他们也是人。他们有特定的沟通方式，有特定的问题建构方式，
that's not always going to align with how you interpret things. And if your primary problem is trauma or interpersonal conflicts or difficulties, you're going to want someone who is specifically able to address that for you rather than going to an everyday therapist or just the first person you find and finding that they don't actually address the things that you're really worried about. You know, therapy, it's expensive. It's quite a bit of money sometimes. and you want to make sure that your money is worth it.
这些并不总是能与你解读事物的方式相契合。如果你的主要问题是创伤、人际冲突或困难，你会希望找一个能专门为你解决这些问题的人，而不是去找一个日常的治疗师，或者随便找的第一个人，结果发现他们根本无法解决你真正担心的那些事。你知道的，做心理治疗是昂贵的。有时候要花不少钱，
And I think that that is really crucial. It might take a little bit longer, but it is worth it. Your money will be more well spent. You will have more trust, more vulnerability if you take your time to choose the right person. Now, we're at this point in the therapy journey that we've been going along through this episode where you've identified the problem, hopefully. You've been to your doctor. You may have been referred to someone.
而你得确保你的钱花得值。我认为这真的至关重要。这可能会稍微花点时间，但这是值得的。只要你花时间去挑选合适的人，你的钱就会花得更值，你会拥有更多的信任感和脆弱感。现在，我们来到了这一集所经历的心理治疗之旅的这个阶段：你已经识别出了问题，希望如此。你已经去看过医生了。你可能已经被转诊给某人了，
and you've kind of identified what kind of help you might need. So what should you expect next? How do you go about entering into your first few sessions? And what are some of the things that you shouldn't expect? All of that and more in just one second. Entering into your first psychology appointment, your first therapy appointment, it can be really scary, especially if it's your first time or you don't really know what to expect.
而且你也大致确定了自己可能需要什么帮助。那么接下来你应该期待什么呢？你该如何开始前几次咨询？有哪些是你其实不应该期待的呢？所有这些以及更多内容，马上揭晓。步入你的第一次心理学预约、第一次心理治疗预约，可能会让人感到非常害怕，特别是如果这是你的第一次，或者你真的不知道该期待什么。
But it's actually really simple. It's nothing to be worried about at all. Before jumping into what we would normally think of as therapy, the person you're seeing needs to lay a bit of groundwork. And you're going to need to help them with that. So they may ask you some questions around whether you've been to therapy before, whether it was recommended to you by your workplace or another healthcare professional. And sometimes if you've been referred for a specific issue or condition,
但其实它真的很简单。完全没什么好担心的。在直接进入我们通常认为的治疗之前，你见的人需要先铺垫一下基础工作。而你需要在这方面给予他们配合。所以他们可能会问你一些问题，比如你以前是否做过心理治疗，是否是你的工作单位或另一位医疗专业人员推荐你来的。有时，如果你是因为某个具体的问题或状况而被转诊的，
they might ask about your family history, what medications you're on, when you began noticing symptoms, things like that. Just basic outline questions. The typical first session, it's going to provide you with an opportunity to outline exactly why you are there. What was the triggering event? What is the problem or the experience of concern? You might not have one, or at least be able to label exactly what's wrong at that moment. That is okay. If you're just feeling a little bit off, if you're not sure what's wrong, that is totally fine. It should not stop you from going to see someone because a therapist or a psychologist, they are there to help you develop the language and the skills to identify exactly what you're going through. Or you may be on the other end of the spectrum and have tons, a number of topics that you want to discuss.
他们可能会询问你的家族史、你在服用什么药物、你是什么时候开始注意到症状的，诸如此类。只是一些基本的大纲问题。典型的第一次咨询，会为你提供一个机会，让你确切地说明你为什么会来这里。触发事件是什么？问题或令人担忧的经历是什么？你可能没有明确的原因，或者至少当时无法确切说出哪里出了问题。没关系的。如果你只是觉得有点不对劲，如果你不确定哪里出了问题，那完全没关系。这不应该阻碍你去看医生，因为治疗师或心理学家，他们就在那里帮助你培养语言表达能力和技能，来明确识别你到底正在经历什么。或者你可能处于光谱的另一端，有一大堆、许多想要讨论的话题。
That's okay as well. You can use your first session to outline these to your therapist and even better take the opportunity to identify which of these things you're worried about, which of these things you want to address are most crucial and you would like to address first. You may often find that some of them are actually very much interlinked and addressing the root cause of one might actually help with the other. expect to do most of the talking, especially in those first sessions. You know, they want to know you. They want to know who you are. They want to be well informed about what you're worried about before they make any assumptions or judgments. And if you're worried about keeping a conversation or whatnot, that's what they're trained to do.
那也没关系。你可以利用第一次咨询向你的治疗师概述这些话题，更好的是，趁此机会明确在你所担心的这些事情中，哪些是你最想解决、觉得最关键、并且希望优先处理的。你可能会经常发现，其中一些问题其实是紧密相连的，而解决其中一个问题的根本原因实际上可能有助于解决另一个问题。要做好心理准备：大部分时间都是你在说话，尤其是在前几次咨询中。你知道的，他们想了解你。在做出任何假设或判断之前，他们想知道你是谁，想充分了解你所担心的事情。如果你担心自己不知道该怎么维持对话之类的，那正是他们受过专业训练要做的事。
They will ask you questions. They will ask you for more details. They will really probe. But obviously, if you're like, I'm not comfortable talking about that right now, it's all up to you. you're in control. If you exit your first session and you feel like, you know, I didn't have much to say, maybe I'm fine, maybe I don't need help, like, ah, I kind of clam shut. I would encourage you to go back a few more times. Sometimes it can take us some time to feel comfortable and vulnerable in a new situation, especially with new people. And if you don't find that you
他们会问你问题。他们会向你询问更多细节。他们会进行深入的探究。但显然，如果你觉得：“我现在不舒服，不想谈这个，”这一切都取决于你，你是掌控者。如果你结束了第一次咨询，觉得自己好像没说太多，“也许我很好，也许我不需要帮助，”或者“啊，我当时有点闭口不言了，”我还是鼓励你多去几次。有时我们需要一些时间，才能在新的情境中、特别是在面对新面孔时感到舒适并展露脆弱。如果你发现自己平时
typically talk about these problems regularly, it can be an adjustment to recognize that you are in a safe, confidential space where the primary purpose, the primary goal is for you to speak freely and without judgment. It takes time to build trust. So sometimes you do need to go back a few times and recognize, okay, well, this is what I can expect. This is what this person is like. I'm safe here. I can say whatever I would like. Furthermore, I think one of the huge, misconceptions is that you're going to come out of every, every session and have experienced some huge revelation or a breakthrough. Often, that is not the case.
并不习惯经常谈论这些问题，那么要意识到自己身处一个安全的、保密的空间里——在这里，主要的意图和目标就是让你畅所欲言、不受评判——这确实需要一个适应的过程。建立信任需要时间。所以有时候你确实需要多去几次，并意识到：“好吧，这就是我可以期待的。这个人就是这样。在这里我是安全的。我可以畅所欲言。”此外，我认为一个巨大的误区是，你觉得每次咨询结束后，都会有什么重大的启示或突破。通常情况下，事实并非如此。
You know, the habits, the thoughts, the emotional reactions we experience on a day-to-day basis, they have been developed and conditioned over a very long period of time. So it is hard to unlearn these in just one or two sessions. Having massive realisations, it's not uncommon, but it's also not going to happen all of the time. So our brain is going to take time to adjust, to follow along, to understand. And if you're feeling a little bit confused or like, you know, you're not making this massive progress, you're not seeing these massive changes in your life from the outset, you're not doing anything wrong. Don't quit.
你知道的，我们日常生活中经历的习惯、想法、情绪反应，是在很长一段时间内形成并被强化的。所以要想在一两次咨询中就改掉这些，是很困难的。有重大的领悟并不罕见，但也不会一直发生。所以我们的大脑需要时间去适应、去跟上、去理解。如果你觉得有点困惑，或者觉得从一开始就没有取得巨大的进展，在生活中看不到巨大的改变，你并没有做错什么。不要放弃。
It's not something to worry about. change, it takes time. Breakthroughs, take time. They require a lot of foundation work, but they will come. And even if they're just going to come along a little bit quieter or less traumatic than you expected, they will happen if you commit to your mental health journey. And you know, therapy isn't going to fix everything. I think that's another big kind of disclaimer I would like to make. But what it will do is give you the necessary strategies and mental or emotional tools to fix those things yourself. And sometimes we just need someone to talk to.
这没什么好担心的。改变需要时间。突破需要时间。它们需要大量的底层基础工作，但它们一定会到来。哪怕它们来得比你预期的要安静一些、没有那么戏剧化，只要你承诺致力于自己的心理健康之旅，它们就会发生。你知道的，心理治疗并不能解决所有问题。我认为这是我想提出的另一个重大免责声明。但它会做的是：赋予你必要的策略和心理或情感工具，让你自己去解决这些问题。有时候我们只是需要找人倾诉。
There is this saying that a problem on a page is half a problem. The same goes for verbalizing it. Often a lot of our worries come from thoughts and feelings that we have that have been suppressed. And once we're able to get those out into the air, you'll feel a lot better. And in six months, I promise that you will notice a change as you begin to kind of see the world and your behaviors and yourself a lot differently, week by week, month by month. But back to those first few sessions, if you have decided that you want to undergo a specific therapy or a specific route, your therapist will likely talk you through
有这样一句话：把问题写在纸上，问题就解决了一半。把问题说出来也是同样的道理。通常我们的许多担忧都来自于被压抑的思想和感受。一旦我们能够把这些倾吐出来，你会感觉好很多。我保证，在六个月后，你会注意到变化，随着你周复一个月、月复一月地开始以截然不同的方式看待世界、看待你的行为以及你自己。但回到那前几次咨询，如果你已经决定要进行某种特定的治疗或走某种特定的途径，你的治疗师很可能会与你深入探讨
this with you. You know, they really want to be involved. That's obviously the point. They're going to speak with you about the process, the steps, the reasoning and the evidence. For example, if you are like, okay, I have a massive phobia of snakes. It's really bothering me. I can't go outside. I can't go on hikes. I can't enjoy nature because I'm so worried about it. They might be like, okay, well, exposure therapy is really going to work here,
这一点。你知道的，他们真的很想参与其中。这显然是重点。他们会跟你沟通这个过程、步骤、背后的逻辑以及依据。举个例子，如果你说：“好的，我极其害怕蛇。这真的困扰我。我不能出门。我不能去徒步。我无法享受大自然，因为我太担心这个了。”他们可能会说：“好吧，那暴露疗法在这里真的很管用，”
and they will talk you through exactly what it entails. They may also offer alternative therapies or alternative treatments based on their professional judgment. You can do your own research and be like, no, I don't want to go down that path. No, I don't really want to do that. it's completely up to you. But by the time that you've been there a few times, you should have a good understanding of what you're working towards
然后他们会向你详细讲解它具体包含什么。根据他们的专业判断，他们也可能会提供替代疗法或替代治疗方案。你可以自己做研究，然后说：“不，我不想走那条路。不，我其实不想做那个。”这完全取决于你。但等你去了几次之后，你应该对你正在努力的方向
and how your chosen mental health professional sees your issue or how they are going about addressing it and the process or the steps that are laid out in front of you. In that first session as well, if, for example, you're having a mental health crisis or you are really struggling with anxiety or depression, they may also offer some initial suggestions or skills to start working on and some activities that you should do between sessions.
以及你所选择的心理健康专业人士如何看待你的问题、他们将如何着手解决这个问题，以及摆在你面前的过程或步骤有一个很好的理解。同样在第一次咨询中，如果你遇到了心理健康危机，或者你真的在和焦虑或抑郁苦苦抗争，他们也可能会提供一些初步的建议、开始着手的技巧，以及你在两次咨询之间应该做的活动。
Maybe it's practicing mindfulness, maybe they will teach you specific calming techniques if you're panicking or recommend a specific journaling routine, and it's your responsibility to complete these. They're not going to tell you off if you didn't do it. It's up to you, but treat it like the most important homework you will ever do. The most important homework of your life, it will be the things that you will be the things that your therapist assigns you to do. I promise it's worth doing them. After the first session, your therapist or psychologist, they will normally book you in for a next session if you decide they are the right person. And you and them will create either a weekly or a fortnightly schedule
也许是练习正念，也许他们会教你具体的镇定技巧（如果你恐慌发作的话），或者推荐特定的写日记惯例，而完成这些是你的责任。如果你没做，他们也不会训斥你。这全看你个人，但请把它当成你这辈子做过的最重要的家庭作业。你一生的最重要的家庭作业，就是你的治疗师指派给你的那些事情。我向你保证，去做这些是值得的。在第一次咨询后，如果你的治疗师或心理学家觉得你觉得对方是合适的人，通常会为你预约下一次咨询。你和他们会建立每周或每两周一次的日程安排，
for you to see them regularly based on their schedule, based on your schedule. I think another huge misconception with therapy is that you have to be going like five times a week, like all the time, to see those results, when truly if you've found the right person for you, you can do a lot of the necessary work between your sessions and with their guidance. If after a little while you have a conversation and you don't really need to see them as regularly, you can always change to a monthly basis. You don't have to stick to that schedule that you initially set. And regardless of what happens, you can always go back even if you take a
根据他们的时间和你的时间，定期与他们见面。我认为关于心理治疗的另一个巨大误区是，你必须每周去五次之类的大多数时间都在去，才能看到效果；而事实上，如果你找到了适合你的人，你可以在两次咨询之间以及在他们的指导下完成很多必要的功课。如果过了一段时间，你们沟通后发现你不需要那么频繁地见到他们了，你随时可以改成按月预约。你不需要死守着最初设定的日程。无论发生什么，即使你休息了一段时间，你随时都可以回去。
break. You can stay in touch with your therapist even if you're not seeing them regularly, especially once that trust is built. It's important to know that you can rekindle that professional relationship. However, that does not mean that you're going to be best pals and should be able to call them or text them in the middle of the night whenever you're having a problem. Remember, they are real people. They are a trained confidential professional service, not a best friend. So make sure that you maintain healthy boundaries and expectations about what a therapist can really offer you and make sure that they are the right person for you. I think that is the crucial message throughout this entire thing. Make sure they are the right person. The growth
即使你不再经常去看心理治疗师，你也可以和他们保持联系，特别是当信任建立起来之后。知道自己可以重新建立这种专业关系是很重要的。然而，这并不意味着你们会成为最好的死党，也不意味着每当遇到问题时，你都可以在半夜打电话或发短信骚扰他们。记住，他们是真人。他们提供的是经过培训的保密专业服务，而不是你的闺蜜。所以一定要保持健康的界限，并对治疗师真正能为你提供什么保持合理的预期，同时确保他们确实是适合你的人。我认为这是贯穿整件事情的关键信息。确保他们是合适的人。你想要看到的成长，
that you will want to see, the changes you will want to see. They will not happen if you do not feel comfortable. They will not happen if you don't feel vulnerable enough to share what is actually really worrying you and if that person isn't, doesn't have the training or the specific skill set that's going to meet your needs. Before we wrap up, and to complete the guide, I really want to quickly address one more myth. And that is that if you seek professional help, something must be wrong with you. You are broken, you are weak, whatever it is. Society has never been particularly kind to people who struggle with their mental health. There is a long history of stigma and mal-treatment. But there is nothing wrong with you. Nothing at all. Almost 25% of all people in the world
你想要看到的改变，如果你感觉不自在，它们是不会发生的。如果你觉得不够脆弱、无法分享真正让你担忧的事，或者如果那个人不具备满足你需求的培训背景或特定技能，这些改变是不会发生的。在我们结束之前，为了让这个指南完整，我真的很想快速再讲一个迷思。那就是：如果你寻求专业帮助，说明你一定有什么毛病。你坏掉了，你很脆弱，诸如此类。社会对那些与心理健康问题苦苦抗争的人从来没有特别友善过。这其中有着漫长的污名化和虐待历史。但你身上没有任何毛病。一点也没有。世界上将近25%的人
will experience some form of mental health condition or struggle in their life. And those numbers just come from the people who actually seek help. I'm guessing they would be so much higher than we can anticipate. You are not alone. You are certainly not weak. Going to therapy does not change anything about your value or who you are. If anything, it only makes you stronger and more well equipped to deal with the roller coaster of life. So if you've made it this far, if you're considering therapy, please, please do it. There are always options out there, affordable help, therapy that's offered through your workplace, through your insurance, through government programs, through online services. And, you know, you don't need to announce it to the work.
会在其一生中经历某种形式的心理健康状况或挣扎。而且这些数字仅仅来自那些真正寻求帮助的人。我猜实际数字会比我们预期的要高得多。你并不孤单。你绝对不脆弱。去看心理治疗并不会改变你的任何价值或你是谁。硬要说的话，它只会让你变得更坚强，装备更充足去应对生活的过山车。所以，如果你已经看到了这里，如果你正在考虑做心理治疗，请、请去做吧。总有各种途径供你选择：负担得起的帮助、通过工作单位提供的治疗、通过你的保险、通过政府项目、通过在线服务。而且，你知道的，如果你觉得不自在，你不需要向全世界宣告，
world if you don't feel comfortable, but I would also really, really encourage you to not let any stigma stop you. You're in the right place, no matter what society thinks, your parents, your friends think on this platform, no matter what you're going through, mental health will absolutely never be something to be ashamed of. And getting help is one of the most crucial things that you can do. It is amazing for you in the long term. It is amazing for your quality of life, for your well, for your ability to be a good person. So I would highly recommend no matter what issue you're facing to kind of follow some of these steps, to really think about if this is the right time for you to go and seek therapy, to think about what you would want from a therapist, to go through
但我还是要非常非常鼓励你：不要让任何污名化阻止你。你走在正确的道路上，无论社会怎么想，无论你的父母、朋友在社交平台上怎么想，无论你正在经历什么，心理健康绝对永远都不是一件需要感到羞耻的事。而寻求帮助是你所能做的最关键的事情之一。它对你的长远发展大有裨益，对你的生活质量、你的幸福感、以及你成为一个优秀之人的能力大有裨益。所以我强烈建议，无论你面临什么问题，都去遵循其中的一些步骤，认真思考现在是不是你去看心理治疗的好时机，想想你希望从治疗师那里得到什么，经历
those initial kind of stages of going to see your doctor, getting some form of mental health assessment or a mental health care plan, and then reaching out to the available services in your area. I think that's a good place to end things. I just really wanted to take some time to actually speak through exactly what it's like from the very beginnings, the very initial thoughts of maybe seeking help to those first sessions. What is that process like so that if you are someone who is considering it, it doesn't seem as scary. It doesn't seem as new. It doesn't seem as out of the ordinary. You know, it's super normal. So I really hope. that you have enjoyed this episode. I'm really proud of you if you're looking to get some extra
去看医生、获得某种心理健康评估或心理健康护理计划的那些初步阶段，然后向你所在地区的可用服务伸出援手。我认为这是一个很好的收尾地方。我只是真的想花一些时间，来实际讲述一下：从最初的萌芽状态——也就是萌生寻求帮助的最初想法——到前几次咨询，整个过程到底是怎样的。这个过程是怎样的呢？这样如果你是一个正在考虑这件事的人，它看起来就不会那么吓人，就不会显得那么新奇，就不会显得那么离经叛道。你知道的，这超级正常。所以我真的希望
help with your mental health. It is amazing. I do it. I'm, I do it. I feel like, you know, I'm here. I'm recording this podcast. I have an amazing life, but sometimes things come and go and there really shouldn't be any stigma around addressing that the same way that you would address a broken arm or a concussion or anything else going wrong in your body. So thank you so much for listening. If this episode has helped you and you think it could help someone else, please feel free to share it. Pass along the good message, pass along the positive vibes and the advice. And if you do feel called to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you are listening right now. It really does help the show grow and reach new people.
你喜欢这一集。如果你正在寻找额外的帮助来改善你的心理健康，我为你感到骄傲。这太棒了。我也这么做。我，我也做心理治疗。我觉得，你知道的，我在这里，我正在录制这个播客。我有着棒极了的生活，但生活有时总会有起伏，而对于解决这些问题，本不该有任何污名化，就像你对待骨折、脑震荡或身体其他出了问题的地方一样。非常感谢你们的收听。如果这一集对你有所帮助，并且你认为它也能帮助到其他人，请随时分享出去。传递好消息，传递积极的能量和建议。如果你真的感到内心有所触动，请随时在Spotify、Apple Podcasts或你现在收听节目的任何平台上留下五星好评。这真的对节目的成长和触达新听众有很大帮助。
So I would very much appreciate it if you would like to. and make sure to follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. That's where this conversation really began. So if you want to stay up to date with what's coming next, if you want to provide some episode suggestions, I will gladly take it on board. And we will be back next week for another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all?
如果你愿意的话，我会非常感激。也请确保在Instagram上关注我们@That Psychology Podcast。我们的对话正是从那里开始的。所以如果你想了解接下来的最新动态，如果你想提供一些节目建议，我都会非常乐意采纳。我们下周将带着另一集回归。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This speech is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's, really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
你正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难学习法》（Learn the Hardway）。这场演讲关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人背负着一身盔甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须如此。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习法》。
In 2023, Bachelor Star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test. twice Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔（Scottsdale）警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请收听《深陷爱河》播客
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立弹性的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。
That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you do. your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
也就是TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This isn't a lot. IHeart Podcasts. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们总是说要相信你的闺女们。请收听《闺蜜们》（The Girlfriends）。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。这不是一个普通的播客。IHeart Podcasts。保证纯正人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。